as just kind of an active sort of
rebellion uh I wrote Fight Club because
I knew they wouldn't buy that either but
I knew that if I did it well enough they
would never forget it and at that point
it was more about revenge than it was
about actually selling
anything so Chuck tell me tell me about
your childhood you grew up where I grew
up in Eastern Washington State uh on a
uh on the Snake River which is a a
tributary of the Colombia River in uh
this huge vast sort of arid desert part
of the state um tell me about your
family my family my family all were kind
of dust bow people who kind of came into
that area uh during the Depression and
they came in lured by the uh the work
provided by the the Hanford nuclear
reactor they came from Montana they came
from North Dakota and uh because the
housing shortage they all ended up
settling in this one small town so at
one point we had uh generations and
generations of my father's family and my
mother's family in this in this town
called Burbank Washington um it was
probably the
most happy glorious time of my life you
know where you're related to half the
people in the town um yeah I wish I had
made more of it I wish IID talked to
them more about uh what had brought them
there and your relationship with your
parents was good it was good you know
um it was good but
boy and I'm sorry I I'm one of these
people that stops a lot and thinks a lot
and that's really difficult for a lot of
people to be with um I'm not going to be
a kind of wall to--all carpet of of talk
MH that's
fun I know your father had an
interesting story my my my my father uh
when he was about three years old his
father had come back from working in the
shipyards in Seattle during World War II
and the family story is that he had
taken a block and tackled it the head
he'd come back a different person and at
one point he had flown into a rage
accusing my grandmother of adultery and
at the time most of the uh most of their
kids were at school and my father was at
home and I believe there was another
sibling at home my father was about
three and there was a gunshot and my
father went around this this this
Farmhouse up in the Idaho mountains
looking for his mother and he couldn't
find his mother and he periodically he
had to hide underneath his bed and his
father was walking around the house
carrying a shotgun uh calling for my
father uh in effect trying to find my
father to kill him also that my my so
your your grandfather suspected his wife
of
adultery and he subsequently shot her
shot the other child who was home
uh walked around the house trying to
find my father to shoot him and then
ultimately shot himself so it was a
murder suicide and uh and then growing
up we were always told that they had
died of
diptheria and then around the age of 21
I was home for Christmas and my mother
said uh oh by the way it wasn't
dpia and she told me the story about the
murder suicide and uh and I said so what
bedroom where were they shot where were
they killed and uh and she got this
funny sad look and she said do you
remember that yellow bedroom that was
off the kitchen that yellow bedroom with
no
windows and I said yeah that was the
bedroom we kids had to sleep in every
summer when we went to visit and she
said uh I felt so bad turning off the
light and leaving you four kids to sleep
in that room every night and uh it was
the creepiest room it had no windows it
had just a door into the kitchen it had
a rollway bed and it was that bed under
which my father had hid to save his life
and it was on that bed that my
grandmother had been killed and then uh
realized that for all those Summers we'd
also slept on that bed uh it was just a
it was a relief to hear the truth um but
it was also kind of an ick moment to to
find out
that you know very little of that house
had
changed and because there was no one to
had the household his older brother had
to be called home and his older brother
had had gotten married moved to Seattle
and had created his own
life and I believe there were 16
siblings all together and the older
brother um my Uncle Pete was so angry
about this that uh that he was uh
fantastically abusive and he would just
beat the younger kids because he was a
young man he was probably 19 or 20 and
suddenly he was in charge of this whole
brood of kids in this in this house in
the middle of nowhere and he beat my
father so badly that uh at one point my
father decided that he was going to
leave home he was going to just set out
and my father was I think about 8 or
nine at that point so he ran away from
home and
and at one point he had been picked up
by a farmer who said come out to my farm
in Moxy which is a Moxy is nothing it's
a it's a rail stop in the middle of
nowhere and you can work on my farm and
I'll give you a place to
stay and something happened that very
first night that my father was at this
Farm in Moxy and it's something that my
father would never talk about but he
ended up running away from that farm in
the middle of the night and he was
arrested for vagrancy and uh put in jail
in walawala and he did talk about that
he did talk about the worst part of his
life was being in jail as an eight or
nine-year-old kid in walawala and how he
could see a a clock tower through his
cell window and eventually one of his
married sisters my Aunt Mary uh showed
up and took custody of him and he was
raised the rest of his growing up with
her so that's that's my father's growing
up and
he must have been heavily affected by
that losing his mother at such a young
age he was he he ended up having this
enormous life of pursuing women he was
good-look and he was very robust in in
his high school annual picture he he he
looks like a grown man he's he he's so
muscular and his muscles are so defined
that he looks more like the coach than
he than he does like a player on any of
the
teams and he was he was also very dark
skinned um as a kind of first generation
Ukrainian peasant uh he was very very
dark and people uh always thought that
my parents were were a mixed race uh my
father looked much more like a African
American or much more like a Hispanic
than like a a
European but uh but but Dad was just
always very attractive and very
charismatic and he could talk to
anyone and he also had this kind of gift
for the for the grand gesture uh the
first time he got married after my
parents divorce uh he decided that he
was going
to and I'm going to backtrack right here
um years ago when I was in college some
friends and I went to Vancouver British
Columbia uh to sell ecstasy in the bars
we took up smuggled all this ecstasy
into
Canada and we were going to go out to
nightclubs and just sell it pay for our
whole trip make a bunch of money go back
to the University of Oregon where we
were students and so one night we had
taken ecstasy we'd sold all of our stock
we were all laying around the floor of
uh the Nelson Place Hotel on Granville
Street this Flop House
Hotel and nobody could sleep so people
were saying what's your strangest
memory and my best friend a guy named
France uh who is now an architect he
said that when he was a kid growing up
in but Montana his parents had sent him
to stay with friends of theirs hundreds
of miles away and the friends had a
florish shop and he was supposed to work
there all summer and and earn money
and at one point the these people at the
florish shop they they woke him up in
Way Before Dawn like two or three 2 or
3:00 in the morning and they had him
load enormous amounts of flowers wreaths
and garlands and all these flowers into
into Vans and they drove these Vans
across the desert for hour after hour in
the middle of
nowhere and they waited next to a
railroad sighting and finally Around
Just Before Dawn a train came over the
horizon and it pulled into this Railway
siding it was the amp Trak Empire
Builder headed from Portland to
Whitefish
Montana and fron and everyone had to
decorate this entire train with all
these flowers and they had to build a
little scaffolding on top of the
engine and people were waking up on the
train and they were cursing frond for
for why is the train stopped why why are
you decorating this train with
flowers and eventually Fran said a car
full of people got out arrived including
a bagpipe player and these people
climbed up on top of the engine and the
bagpipe player played as the sun was
coming up in the desert and it was
incredibly freezing
cold and a man got up with a minister
and a bride and they got married on top
of the end
while there was a small wedding
party and as soon as the ceremony was
over uh frons and and crew they had to
strip the train so it could continue
along its
way and at the first beat of Silence I
said
fron that that guy who got married on
the train that was my dad and this was
decades before I ever met France and so
the guy who is now my best friend in
College when he was my age as a little
kid had decorated this train because my
father who worked for the Burlington
Northern had this great idea that he was
just going to stick it to my first
mother my first mother he was going to
stick it to his first wife by having
this enormous wedding on a train that
was going to be a big publicity stunt to
prove how much more he loved the second
woman Rita than he loved his first wife
Carol and at the time in the mid 70s I'm
there in a leisure suit and some sort of
macain necklace as part of this wedding
party shaking because it's so cold with
this bagpipe player and this screaming
bag pipes on top of a train full of
angry people in the
desert because my dad just wants this
this giant
stunt oh my gosh my my Dad's life is
just full of these giant stunts and
uh afterwards we got off the train they
stripped the train we went to this uh
Grange hall for the wedding reception
and the the whole thing stayed like a
giant unfolding acid trip it was such a
strange day but then 25 years later to
find myself in school on ecstasy laying
on the floor in a bag Hotel hearing this
story from somebody who at that time had
been a total
stranger um was just so bizarre and
disturbing and
incredible um and my life is full of
those things that are completely
implausible but they happened
anyway
um yeah boy my father was always doing
those gigantic gigantic things
um for whatever reason I'm not sure I
think you know he just he was kind of a
showman but he also really wanted to
host these experiences for
people even if it meant sort of playing
the fool he wanted to create this thing
this event that people would remember as
you remember that time we climbed up on
a train and dad got married and the was
that bagpipe
player just everything about it he he
just didn't want it to be forgotten we
often compensating or or
overcompensating
for
childhood things that happened or didn't
happen in our you know when we were
young well the love that we didn't get
or in his case losing his mom at an
early
age he also he he was also one of these
uh garage invent and he was always
inventing things that he said would
would Deliver Us from poverty he would
always hold up the the bread tab at
breakfast and he would say the man who
invented this never ever had to work
another day in his
life and so there was always this idea
that if you just got one thing right uh
you'd be on Easy Street for the rest of
your life um and so in a way I I still
think that about every book uh and so
ultimately every book is a failure
because it doesn't deliver me to this
kind
of ongoing ecstasy and and sort of
infantili perfection um but dad's
inventions were always kind of bizarre
and dangerous and my brother and I still
laugh about just how um how we almost
got killed by every
invention and your father you eventually
lost him right and that's that's the
other odd half of of the uh murder
suicide
story is that Dad was always always
looking
for the right woman in a in effect
always looking for his mother the way he
was looking for her the day that she was
killed and he answered a personal zad uh
in a in a community newspaper and the ad
was headed the headline was Kismet which
I believe is Arabic for fate
so headline is fate and uh it's your
standard ad about a a quiet
contemplative woman is looking for a man
who's not afraid to be a man and looking
for long walks on the
beach and uh what my father didn't know
was that um the woman who had ran the ad
um had been a uh a lawyer in the prison
system in Missouri and she'd fallen in
love with a a prisoner and she had
helped get him out of prison and she had
married him and he had subsequently
molested her daughter and so she was in
the process of having having him sent
back to
prison and he had vowed that if he ever
caught her with another man he would
kill them both my father had no idea
that this was going on and then later
during the trial for this
man uh the the the daughter the daughter
who had been uh molested by him uh she
told me that uh that her mother really
did not like my father it's just that he
was the biggest guy who answered the ad
that she realized she was in danger and
she needed a really big guy to kind of
be her bodyguard and really not know
that he was more or less her bodyguard
and so my father had no idea what he
what he was walking
into and at one point he was going to
hide her out at his house in the
mountains so he had cleaned everything
in the house the house was spotless
everything was perfect and then he had
gone picked her up on the way back to
his house they had stopped at a kind of
uh Community
festival and the people who saw them at
this Lilac Festival said that they they
seemed very very happy very very in in
love with each other and on the way out
they were going to stop by um building a
house that she had under construction
because she wanted to feed some animals
that were kept
there she went to the house with him uh
the ex-husband followed them there uh
the ex-husband shot them both uh they
managed to drag themselves into the
house the ex-husband Set Fire to the
house
and
the medical
examiner
said they died of the
gunshots not the
fire but there was a test I didn't want
to ask about because it would have been
conclusive and it might have proved that
they had died of the fire and I prefer
to think that they that they died of the
gunshots um my siblings could not bring
themselves to go to the trial or to
watch any of the discovery
process so it was really important for
me that in the event that they ever came
to me and said what what what what took
place I I wanted to have this meticulous
you know explanation and that was that
as dad was on the porch above ground
level he was shot from below and the
bullet entered and pierced his
diaphragm and so for the next 20 minutes
every time he breathed air hair got
below the diaphragm and so his lungs had
gradually smaller and smaller space
because there was more and more air
accumulated below his his lungs and so
that means that he would have been
shorter and shorter of breath for about
20 minutes until he ultimately uh uh
passed out and
died and so I just really wanted to have
this this very forensic understanding of
the mechanism by which he died
anyway they're in this house they've
been shot the house is on fire uh the
the the the murderer has left the
scene and ultimately what saved my
father's body was that in the house he
hid underneath a bed just as he had
hidden underneath the bed to avoid his
murderous
father and the bed had fallen in such a
way that it it kind kind of completely
sheltered his body it kept his body from
being
burned and so the parallel between that
and his avoiding the original man with a
gun who was trying to kill him uh
another strange little detail was
that on the day he left his house to go
pick up his girlfriend a giant boulder
has had to slod from the Hillside and
had blocked this very very long
driveway and that my
father
uh was was so intent on going out that
day that he got a block and tackle and
he moved the boulder off the driveway
and then to turn the boulder into a kind
of landmark to their budding
relationship he got he got his electric
router and he got some wood and he
routed a sign that said Kismet Rock and
he painted it and he varnished it and he
put it on a steak next to this Boulder
which still sits next to his
driveway he made it a little Landmark so
that when he brought his beloved back he
could point to it and say that is a
reference to your personal at that is a
little Landmark that stands for our new
relationship our new happiness and she
never saw it the only people who saw it
were my brother and and I who showed up
at his house looking for his dental
records uh because they had found this
body H just so much
um anyway but the Perfection of that
that so many things at the end of his
life had paralleled so many things at
the beginning of his life um was a a
really strange wonderful Comfort because
it seemed like a a kind of
symmetrical
inevitability that he should die in
exactly this
way
um boy when the medical
examiner
uh was showing me the pictures of the
body he said this is my my procedure he
had these these crime scene photos and
he put a a piece of copy paper over the
top and he said I'm gonna
pull the paper aside very very slowly
and you tell me when you've seen enough
you tell me when to
stop and like Chinese water torture he
starts to pull it and he's pulling it as
slow as the minute hand on a clock he's
pulling it so
slow and I can't tell what's what little
I'm seeing I can't tell anything and
just out of frustration finally I I
reach out and I grab the paper and I say
enough geez just let rip the scab off
and I pulled it to the side and there's
my dad partially burned up with a big
gunshot he looks terrible and I can deal
with that I love my father but I didn't
need the slow Agony of that that that
slow
reveal um he wasn't in the pugilist
position because my first way of
understanding anything is to Deep dive
into all the nuts and bolts and
typically when you die in a fire your
body draws up really
tightly all the all the the joints sort
of Buckle in and that the hands form
fists and so uh forensics U calls that
the pugilist
position like you're a boxer and my
father had been a boxer my my my father
had been a champion boxer in the Navy
and the first time I knew that my
parents were divorced ing for good was
when all of his boxing trophies
disappeared off the uh bookcase in the
living room and we we never knew what
happened to them mom just took them and
just threw them out but uh
anyway that was my dad's
death and the
part that I never ever told anybody
because it's a stupid part the stupid
part is only stupid because because it
uh because it doesn't sound like
forensics but I had bought this
house uh the house I live in now and it
was a a giant wreck of a house on this
rock outcropping it kind of hangs over
this enormous uh Gorge called the
Columbia
Gorge it's like something out of an
Edgar Allen Poe novel the setting is so
dramatic and the house had been
fantastic Ally run down and it had been
owned by hoarders for decades and so
once it was cleared out uh we brought in
Architects and designers and all these
people and the house was completely gut
remodeled and filled with a bunch of
furniture I'd never seen before and for
about two
weeks I lived in an apartment in in a
barn at the far end of the
property and for two weeks the designer
said you cannot go in the house because
we're we're hanging Hing curtains we're
putting up the wallpaper we are rolling
out the rugs we're setting everything
where where it's going to go and we want
to have a big reveal so for two weeks
you may not look in the house you may
not go in the house but every evening
you should walk over and check the doors
to make sure they're all locked so for
two weeks in the fall of maybe
2010 I would go to the house and I would
check all the doors and then I would
take the long walk back to the barn
where I where I was
staying and all the leaves were down and
there were all these really
bright uh horse chestnut leaves bright
yellow so so the ground is brighter than
the sky that that incredible sort of lit
From Below feeling and as I'm walking
back in the
evening I was thinking boy I wish my dad
was alive to see this house dad would
just really love this
house and
uh and I went back I went to sleep I
went to bed and that night I dreamt my
father came to
me and my mother had died my father died
in 99 my mother died 10 years later in
2009 and this was in about 2010 that I'm
having this dream and in the dream my
father walks into this apartment that I
had in the barn and he
says
um he says for 10 years I didn't know I
was dead and I walked
around and finally your mother came to
me and said Fred you're dead it's
okay which
is jibes with the fact that after my
father's death my mother kept on having
these reoccurring dreams where my father
was coming to her door and he'd been
shot and he was bleeding and he would he
would every in every dream he'd say
Carol can can you hide me you've got to
hide me someone's trying to kill me
someone's shot me and he's he's trying
to kill me and in every dream my father
would shut the door and say Fred you did
this to yourself deal with
it but then subsequently I'm having this
dream after they're both dead and dad
says I wandered around your mother came
to me she said you're
dead
um and then he said I'd really like to
see your house house will you show me
your
house so we walked back in the dream
through the woods to the
house and we walked through the house
and I I'd never been in the house since
it was all
staged and in one upstairs hallway which
has no you know there's no sideline to
any Windows there was a a series of very
brightly colored prints they were these
kind of Stripes of
color uh really bold Stripes of color
color on these uh these framed artworks
that were hanging on the wall in this
kind of Upstairs
Gallery and I they struck me and then F
my father walked into a room and he said
I just want you to know that I am more
happy than I ever could have been on
Earth you cannot imagine the kind of
happiness and joy that I exist in all
the time right now and
in the dream he's shirtless and he's
very young and he's just glowing he's
glowing like he's made out of gold he's
so
bright and he says is there anything
you'd like to ask
me and in that moment I had all the this
did it hurt what's it like are you in
heaven I had all these
questions but at the same time I
realized that he had
demonstrated through all of his actions
he had demonstrated
all these things already and for me to
ask these questions would be kind of
insulting because they would kind of
negate all this effort that he had gone
to to sort of perform how happy he
was and I said no I don't have any
questions but thank you and he he said
I'm going to lay down and go to sleep
and he laid down across the bed in the
master bedroom and he disappeared
and at that moment I woke up in the
apartment in the barn and I'm just
sobbing oh my
God I am just like little kid sobbing
just roaring with
tears and that's the day that the
designers are going to walk me through
the house that I have not been in and so
I pull it together I meet the designers
they say you're going to love what we've
done with this
house they walk me through the house
walk me through the house then we get to
that Upstairs Gallery
hallway and there are those prints that
there's no way I could have seen them
and I'm just staring at
them I can't breathe I can't speak they
are exactly the prince from the dream I
could I could not have seen them through
any window
they just completely impossibly
there and I couldn't speak after that
the whole rest of the tour I I just was
just following and later the designer
said that the look on my face they
thought I hated it they thought I was
Furious that I hated everything that
they had done and they thought that they
just massively failed on all counts but
no it was because those those paintings
those colorful prints were just so
inexplicable yeah anyway um I uh they
said is there anything you like changed
I said those prints have got to go I I
can't live with those
um but that
is the ridiculous part and you can't say
the ridiculous part um so I collect the
ridiculous Part I
if I if I'm brave enough I'll throw that
story out because it will it
will catalyze similar stories from other
people and I collect these stories
because anecdotally they don't prove
anything but I'm looking for
commonalities between
them because they're just gorgeous and
people don't get a chance to tell them
because people are very self-conscious
about them and in a way turning them
into words
kind of dishonors them
um yeah it kind of diminishes them to
make them into
words but when I hear them I I I they're
just so enormously moving
um and I collect lots of stories I
collect the the uh the workplace hazing
stories people love
those oh I collect the uh when did your
parents tell you about sex stories
because those form a pattern and they're
generally really funny and
universally um they a universal
experience but the stories that people
have about being contacted by dead loved
ones and inexplicable things that happen
are just
such impossible
stories uh to
tell and to honor because I I for
whatever reason yeah but but I adore
them and I I collect them from
everyone is do you think
the you absurd ways that your
father you know the things he went
through the way he almost died as a
child and then the terrible murder when
he was older do you think that's
impacted or affected the way that you
you write
now looking looking for these
extreme like almost almost
uncomfortable experiences and
stories
um I think it does
because my ongoing sense is that that
life is so much more enormous and
extreme and incredible than we ever are
led to believe or or that we are allowed
to believe and we all have these kind of
stories exactly and and they're the kind
of stories that
just are not sort of deemed appropriate
or not deemed believable so that they
tend to be stories that
just never really get recorded or turned
into a product they're never shared
exactly um and it's funny we I think
we're we're each raised with a kind of
Mythology from our
parents they'll tell us about things
that happened to us or things that we
did
that we we're no longer aware of we we
don't have the memory
itself um and one of my mother's
favorite stories was uh
um when uh when I was three years old
about the age when my father wasn't shot
uh I I developed this huge growth on my
neck and I've never told this story
because it's one of those crazy
stories that just makes me look like a
crazy person
I developed this huge growth on my neck
and our physician you know in
1965 thought it was a form of fibrous
tuberculosis and they needed to to
operate to see if it was this
tuberculosis and so I was taken to Our
Lady of Lord's hospital and they gave
three-year-old me uh a
surgery and I quit breathing and I
stopped breathing during the surgery and
the doctor came out to my mother who was
very early 20s and said we're really
sorry but your child is dead um he's
been dead for about three minutes uh we
can't revive him uh little little
Charles is
dead and my mom sat down
and
whatever was in disbelief and time went
by and sometimes it's 12 minutes and
sometimes it's 20 minutes but eventually
the doctor came back back out and
said your child's alive again he started
breathing he's he's back we don't know
how but he's back and so my mother loved
to tell that story because in one moment
her her kid was dead and then she was
completely in the abyss
and some impossible time later her kid's
alive again
and yeah I have no memory of it
but but to tell the truth not very much
has surprised me about my
life I always kind of knew that I would
completely sort of waste and [__] up my
20s and I always knew that something was
going to happen to me around the age of
30 to
32 and that I always knew that that
thing would
accelerate and so part of not being kind
of oh more overwhelmed by be be becoming
a public figure or becoming a writer
becoming anybody was this
strange half awareness that these things
were were there they were just you know
waiting for me to reach a certain age um
a while back I was in in my driveway and
uh and a truck was coming down the
Highway and it had uh taken a curve way
too fast and I could see that the the
tongue on the trailer was bent and the
whole trailer was up on two wheels and
it was about just about to dump it this
huge trailer full of concrete and
boulders and steel uh they were tearing
down a
dam and I thought oh he is going to
spill it right there and the whole
thing's going to come sliding into my
car and then suddenly the trail trailer
overcompensates and tilts the other way
towards me and it's up on two wheels on
my side and I think
okay and part of me thought this is it
then part of me knew no this isn't it
this is not it because I'll know when
when it is it and the whole thing dumped
on my car and crushed my car and threw
my car up into the woods and I was
trapped in my
car uh
until the jaws of life people came and
the funny thing is my phone started to
ring while I was still trapped in the
car and no emergency services were there
yet uh just buried in all this Rubble my
phone is ringing and it is my agent uh
who was a very proper Englishman and uh
and he's saying oh Chuck I've got
wonderful news for you um I said yeah
Edward I'm trapped in my car it's a
Prius I don't know if it might
explode uh but I'm all burned up from
the airbag powder my my skin is just all
raw and uh all the glass is shattered so
I'm surrounded by all this safety
glass and Edward's saying no no it won't
take just a moment I'm think no
seriously Edward I'm smashed in this car
I'm not sure if I'm going to burn alive
or what and he goes no no no no just let
me let me talk and he proceeds to tell
me that he sold the rights to my my
novel haunted uh for a movie and uh and
he goes I'll ring off now and so there
was never a word about you know good
luck getting out of the car uh it was
just a a call from my agent while I'm
trapped in the
car but even in that moment when I
thought this could be it I knew this
wasn't it that um I've had this kind of
strange awareness and I might as well
talk about it here because uh
ah you
know because my grandmother would always
get these really incredibly beautiful
crocheted and Lace napkins or
tablecloths place mats and she'd always
say this is too good to use this is too
nice we should put this away it's too
nice to use and then she got
diverticulitis and her colon ruptured
and she died in fantastic pain and when
we went to sort through her house there
were all of these napkins and crocheted
collars and place mats and tablecloths
that were too good to use
and they all went to Goodwill they never
got used so screw
it
um if I can think of a story if I can
think of an idea I've got to find a way
to put it in a book I'm not going to be
one of these people who sort of stops
the
supply
by by just thinking ah I'm going to hold
this back I'm going to hold this back um
because that's when you quit getting
good ideas that's when you quit hearing
good stories is when you are so holding
tightly um to the stories that you've
got you have you have the censorship
censorship of others to combat to create
that problem already you don't need to
sensor yourself
in a way it's uh others don't even
figure into it um they
will yeah I don't care if they like it
or they don't like it what matters is
that it gets out there and it gets out
in such a way that it that it is
remembered that is it's that sort of
whether you call it extremeness of it or
truth of it that will keep it in the
culture long enough that the culture
will eventually change and embrace the
thing you you create for yourself not
for your
audience
exactly
um and if you do it right then you're
creating for both because you're
generating a thing that they see
themselves in um after my father's death
my father in his
retirement had been a crazy contest
junkie and he subscribed to all these
magazines that told you where to send a
th000 postcards with a th000 entries for
some Campbell super contest so my father
would enter all of us kids and all of
his peers and all of his siblings and
everyone around him in as many contests
as he could find and so after he
died for years we got this kind of slow
trickle flood of little tiny useless
things that just came out of nowhere
they were like cble soup mugs and they
were like um golf towels that that were
merchandising for a certain brand of
cheese they were all small sort of
pointless things and they were all
called you consolation prizes which I
thought was so poignant that in a way
Dad is dead and we're getting all these
prizes that Dad registered registered us
for to console us and I told that story
and a young woman I worked with who
worked for Detroit art
Services she just she's so bright and
she got this huge smile and she said my
dad did that too my dad was at contest
junkie and after he died I got little
useless things for years and years and
each one was like this sweet little joke
for my father and so when you are able
to articulate your experience you give
other people the
opportunity to recognize that their
experience is not so crazy or silly uh
that they can't talk about it themselves
you give them a a permission you give
them an authority um by doing so
first yeah you kind of open up the
conversation like we we can talk about
this kind of crazy stuff and it and then
then it just spreads from there because
we all have
them and going back to college I there
was so many courses I took where no one
would really want to discuss whatever
we'd been assigned to read and I
remember once sitting in a in a course
about beol
breast in a room full of 20 25 college
kids and no one wanted to talk about
this Brean play and I thought I am
paying this much money and I'm spending
this big chunk of time to sit in a room
full of quiet people none of whom want
to look like the idiot so I would
finally just say you know I think bre
blah blah blah and I'd say some
completely outlandish stupid
thing but it would provoke everyone else
to jump in and say are you an idiot are
you crazy no of course that wasn't bre's
intention and the conversation would be
started because I threw myself on the on
the hand grenade I I made myself the
stupid one and I think sometimes that's
the greatest gift you can do is to draw
enemy fire to make yourself the stupid
one so that nobody else has to be the
stupid one first um and you give them
permission to to to be out there because
you've already sort of you've already
sort of been the dumb one or or told the
embarrassing story or or
whatever so so your career as you
mentioned earlier you referred to
your the path of your life changing in
your was it was it 20s or 30s you know
it because you weren't you weren't a
writer your whole life no you
know I only wanted to be a writer in
grade school because if you got into a
certain writing program you got taken to
this camp in the woods which looked
absolutely beautiful and where we lived
in the desert with Sage Brush and
Cactus boy the idea of going it was at
the ocean to going to the ocean to be in
all these
trees I I didn't care what they did it
could have been a cooking camp it could
have been a boy Satan worshiping Camp I
just wanted to go there it was so
beautiful
looking so I started writing Poes trying
to get into this Camp
um yeah other than that it was not
really a driving wanting to be a writer
until I you know became a a studied
journalism in
college because it seemed like a
practical way to get in and journalism
wasn't
uh wasn't my dream either because so
much of it was about
uh in a lot of cases creating conflict
my editor would tell me to to say to lie
to City officials and to attribute those
lies to other City officials and to
create this kind of
conflict and just so I'd have something
to report on and I couldn't bring myself
to do that so I eventually had to leave
that job but
uh yeah you became a right what kind of
jobs were you doing before you became a
writer uh went to college journalism
wrote uh as a Stringer all through
college magazine pieces wrote for small
newspapers came out of college and uh
went to work for Freightliner uh first
on the assembly line in Portland station
210 building trucks and I worked there
for over three years before I got
promoted to something called the r&m
center where we ran these enormous
machines uh to study how things broke
down to study how windshield wipers
would eventually break or uh switches
for uh headlights uh these these
machines were enormous simulation just
ran for for days or months or years so
that when they did break down we could
study how they broke down I wrote uh
repair and uh I wrote recall and service
bulletins and uh repair procedures and
then traveled around the country
teaching them at different
dealerships um so that was another 10
years I was I was at freight liner for
13 years and you became a
writer a serious writer
you know boy in the early 90s I started
with a teacher named Tom spanbauer who
was teaching a style called minimalism
and minimalism was so different from the
pros fiction that it kind of really put
me off of reading uh minimalism was
closer to song lyrics and
so minimalism was was a great fit it was
also a great fit with the kind of
journalistic writing I was doing so
minimalist
ISM and then technical writing
um and then I started trying to write uh
a short story called Fight Club trying
to write it more like a song with
choruses it would be three verses a
bridge and choruses and it worked so
well that it really created this this
style uh of trying to write short
stories and chapters like they were
songs and my teacher the man who taught
me minimalism he always had us read our
work out loud and
so it became more about that kind of
performative quality where the story
could only be a certain length and it
had to be paced in such a way that it
was more like singing a story than it
was about reading a story um and that
that just made all the difference
suddenly it was it was not this Pros
thing and it wasn't a poetry thing it
was something in between that was almost
like a movie because it was cut so
cleanly by these choruses or whatever
devices and from
there all of my work became this new
kind
of almost more like collage than than
like pros um and that would have been
around 1994
95 because I wrote Fight Club in 94 sold
it 95 book came out in
96 movie came out in
99 I quit my day job in
98 yeah
in Fight Club was your first novel no
I'd actually written two I'd written a
horrible horrible really very long novel
called if you lived here you'd be home
already and that was 800 pages of crap
it was just Dreadful it had two scenes
that were worth salvaging and one went
into fight club it was the the speech
that Mara gives about the the condom
being the glass slipper of a
generation you put it on you dance all
night with a stranger you throw it away
that got lifted from that first terrible
novel and put into fight club and then I
wrote a
over-the-top sort of uh road trip novel
called invisible monsters and that was
based on reading Vogue magazine these
big old F fashion magazines in the uh
laundry mat where I did my laundry every
Tuesday and I just love the chaos of
those magazines half the pages weren't
numbered and stories would start and
then they jump to the back of the of the
magazine and you could never find them
and as you were trying to find the rest
of the story you would keep paging
through and you would find photographs
you'd never seen no matter how many
times you had looked at this magazine
you would I would continually find these
things and it was back during the era of
uh perfume cards so you were just it
wasn't just chaotic it was uh
overstimulating it was
was uh confusing and it had this sort of
barrage of different odors that would
come out of it as you were going back
and forth through these tattered old
magazines and so I'd written this book
in invisible monsters based on the
Dynamics of those magazines all the sort
of chaos of them and the over-the-top
sort of very fluid uh um pros of those
magazines that kind of you know uh I
joke that it was like 500 adjectives all
leading up to the word sweater um you
had no idea what the thing was until you
got to the noun um and that's that
became invisible
monsters and got me an agent and every
publisher wanted it and they flew me to
New York and I did a reading at the KGB
bar and ultimately nobody bought it no
no publisher bought it because they said
our marketing people say they have no
idea what shelf it would go on on it's
not romance it's not comedy it's not
literary Fiction it's not horror they
just don't know where it would be
stocked in the bookstore
so we nobody acquired it and then as
just kind of an active sort of rebellion
uh I wrote Fight Club because I knew
they wouldn't buy that either but I knew
that if I did it well enough they would
never forget it and at that point it was
more about revenge than it was about
actually selling anything anger is a
great fuel isn't it it's a really great
feel I always tell people when they get
dumped you know your husband's divorcing
you this is the write a book this is the
best time to write a book absolutely oh
man my my whole life is built on that
the the love I didn't get from my father
when I was young is what fueled my whole
career in
advertising it's a great little battery
and and if if it's used creatively I
mean if it's if it's it's channeled
productively and also a lot of people
are really afraid of sort of uh
exhausting that battery but even when
you exhaust that battery there's another
battery behind it too yeah you break up
with a girlfriend and there's there's
another one yeah there's always some
horrible unresolvable thing that you can
go to anger is the best fuel yeah it's
high octane fuel and anger and shame
shame is a little harder to harness but
a lot of my books are really about
cringe
shame because uh I think for young
people uh that just a tough place to go
to and if you can be the one that that
that t that coaches them there that's a
real
service so tell me about Fight Club
fight clubs seem to have tapped into
something for
men that they that that these
Generations your generation and and
younger ones Our Generation and younger
ones never h never had in their lives we
didn't have
a great War we didn't have the
depression to overcome we didn't have
any huge challenges to
overcome and Fight Club seemed to been
like almost this
man-made challenge for this group of
young men in the movie that resonated
with everyone every
man
you know at the time I was writing it
all my friends were 31 uh so much so
that we joked we called ourselves the 30
wonderful club and we had all
reached uh the end of the formula uh we
had all gone to college we had all
gotten the job we had all just followed
all all the steps that were supposed to
take you to
happiness and none of
us uh felt
like we had done anything but except for
anything but what we had been told to do
and we'd been so obedient and been so
high
performing but the the the the rewards
just weren't
there and uh and we were at the point
where we could either lapse back into
inauthenticity
where we just keep playing the
game uh fully aware that the game's not
working or we do something different we
do something radically
different and
so all of us started to just kind of act
out in
these uh these fairly institutionalized
ways but for one uh for me it was the
cacophony society that people people on
the west coast had formed these these
participatory groups where they would
stage these big public pranks or throw
these giant sort of underground parties
and this was at a time when uh you know
before the internet when these things
had to be typed up and mimeographed and
mailed to you and so people would host
these giant experiential sort of uh [__]
shows one was the art Mall that Portland
Oregon had this first Thursday where on
the first Thursday of each month all the
art galleries were open and all of the
sort of jordash wearing yuppies would
drink wine and eat cheese and Wander
from one gallery to
another and cacophony we decided that we
were going to we knew of a gallery that
was failing and we were going to get
that gallery for one night for a first
Thursday and so we went around to every
thrift store and we got the worst
cheesiest most
atrocious obscene art that we could find
just complete ah dra and we staged this
whole Gallery with all this really
terrible terrible art and uh we had
these bad performance artists and we had
these incredibly bad mes we had every
art cliche we could find and I remember
one friend Janet she had these words on
pieces of paper and uh as people entered
she would give them a piece of paper and
she would say you must use this word at
least five times before you leave the
gallery and uh I remember somebody got
the word phow Centric but they were all
these really high futin art Theory
words uh and all these very nice
intentioned Jord Dash wearing yuppies
came parading through our gallery and
were initially appalled and angry that
they've been duped into this this big
joke but that ultimately everyone was in
our gallery and the place was packed and
you could not get in um because it was
really a lot of fun and everyone just
loved our bad art gallery that was open
one day La art mall and then just
disappeared but
kaky they would create the they would
float these ideas these stunts of
Burning Man was a cacophony thing
Burning Man is probably the most
high-profile cacophony Society thing
that was uh sort of co-opted or adopted
by the
culture and Santa Rampage was another
where everyone would dress as Santa
Claus and just perform these giant
stunts and these huge public sort of
drunken spectacles with everyone sort of
negating race and gender by all dressing
with these huge beards and these big fat
suits
um Santa Rampage L art Mall oh apoc oh
apoc apocalypse Cafe they would send
these moving trucks these old rider
trucks around to different points in the
city and you would have to show up with
like a potluck hot dish and you would
have to dress for a potluck at the end
of
civilization and the truck would pull up
and the back would roll up and we
realized we would have to be get into
this truck which is illegal and we would
have to be sort of trusting enough that
we would be trucked around to wherever
this huge secret party
was and so everyone was sitting in the
back of these big dark trucks crammed
together with baked beans and all these
other hot dishes and then eventually the
trucks would you know open up and we'd
be in some giant
warehouse but it was these giant sort of
pre-ra events
that kakop
staged and that was a big sort
of early sort of inspiration for Fight
Club this idea of a structured
consensual chaos that you could
enjoy for a very small part of your
weekend uh and then go back to your in
your your boring life on
Monday did did Fight Club start as a
short story it did it was a short story
I wrote at my desk one
afternoon uh when I was bored um I
tweaked it a a couple times but more or
less chapter six is that short story
that I wrote in one setting one
day the gem comes out of one little sit
down
well it's kind of
uh I've read a lot about lyricists who
get more or less an entire song in one
sitting and in one in one case I'm
thinking of John Denver he got into a
fight with his
wife and he decided he was going to ride
the ski lift up to the top of a mountain
and just in the course of that one ride
on the ski lift he came up with the
entire I think it was Annie song
um it was a song where he was he's
really singing about his love of his
wife with whom he's just had this fight
but it was a the song that was sung at
every single one of my peers weddings
through the 70s into the 80s everyone
had someone sing any song um you fell up
my senses like a night in the forest um
like the mountains in springtime like a
walk in the rain like a storm in the
desert like a sleepy blue ocean you fill
up my senses come come fill me again
come let me love you let me give my life
to you Let Me Drown in your some maybe
drown in your anyway that entire song
came to him in one ski lift ride
um yeah and I think that that is the
case when when an idea
strikes
uh one one Hallmark of a good idea is
that it strikes fully and it strikes
very fast uh the whole thing comes
together in an
instant but it's the culmination of
years of experiences and and
life it is it leads to it but at some
point unless there's a sense that it's
come from something else that it's not
so much you you putting it together it
is you channeling something you kind of
providing a kind of reception for
something that is I think the most
hallmarked thing that if you're too
aware of what it is or you feel like
you're really laboring over it
um that doesn't bode
well um for
years
I I wrote back and forth with the writer
IR 11 um because IR 11 was just really a
hero in our family you know before
Stephen King IR 11 was the horror
writer and IR 11 liked my book diary and
endorsed it so we started writing back
and forth and I was always asking him uh
if Rosemary's Baby uh which is arguably
his biggest book whether it was really
it seized public attention it hit so big
because it was expressing the tragedy
and the horror of uh
theide and he was never say uh never say
yes or no he did say that in the early
60s he had wanted to write
about the horror of being pregnant but
not really realizing the nature of what
you were pregnant with and he said that
the there had been a book called the mid
Witch
cucko uh about a bunch of young women in
the same Village becoming pregnant all
on the same night and it was ultimately
made into the Village of the Damned as a
movie Nobody Knows the midwich cuckoo
but they know Village of the Damned
and since it had been done with aliens
he couldn't go there and so he had just
kind of gone to the devil as a
default but when you read Rosemary's
Baby there are some really telling
little details at one point Laura Louise
is knitting booties and Rosemary
Woodhouse is looking at these booties
and she's thinking boy Laura Louise is a
terrible Knitter because these look like
they're booties for something with
flippers or
Claws and what she's describing is more
or less the sort of signature um U
deformations caused by thalidomide uh
these these people who now call
themselves fids like lobster Lobster Boy
uh had these sort of truncated hands and
arms that uh were were more like a claw
like a lobster's
claw and
so there's so many things in Rosemary's
Baby the point to
thalidomide that I couldn't help but
think that you know people are not
really freaked out about a woman being
raped by the devil they are being
allowed to be freaked out about this
huge tragedy they cannot talk about with
the lamide they can't there's no way to
resolve this enormous 20-year horror
we're going to have to live with it it's
going to be with us but we've got to
find some enormous cathartic way to vent
our sadness our anger our everything
around it and so when Rosemary's Baby
came out and we couldn't even see the
baby in the Cradle because it was too
shocking I know that R 11 was writing
about the lamide and that he would get
crucified if if he ever got caught um
crucified for exploiting this tragedy
and so I think in a way maybe Ira didn't
even know he was writing about it but I
think after the fact you always
recognize it it might take you years but
you always recognize what you were
really writing
about and I think that unless you if you
did know about it you would not go to
the fullest extent that you should that
needs to remain a mystery to you or or
you just won't go there it's about
tricking yourself to go there first and
then tricking other people to go
there do you ever sense
yourself just think this is a little bit
too out
there oh I always censor
myself oh my
God I really like Joe Rogan I really I
think he's a great conversationalist and
he's funny he's incredible and it's a
great show to to be
on but the last time I was on there we
we started riffing down this road about
how do you know when your dick is too
big and and I said it's too big when it
hangs in the water and Rogan goes uh we
we're just tossing back and forth to
each other and Rogan goes yeah but
that's it's never too big because then
what you do is you go you have got to go
out and find this find a gal who's like
had six kids and it won't be too big for
her so you just got to go out and find
them one of those gals with a big
stretched out
[__] and I so so Wonder wanted to toss
back and I'm like yo yo joe you ever
been one of those football player guys
those guys take forever to [__] you ever
fisted one of those guys he's like
taking it up the elbow yeah it's like
it's like throwing a sausage down a
hallway Joe you ever been you know one
of those great big big guys you know
those powerlifter guys you know they got
a gape on them like
this and I think you would have laughed
he would have but I think his audience
would have just been so scandal ized and
I just thought self-censor self-censor
my audience can handle it I think your
audience can and that's
why I
I that's why I think you're
uh yeah I love I love doing this because
I feel total freedom like I'm not
getting pushed back from really anybody
like YouTube seems to be pretty good
with allowing me to put almost anything
up some some things I can't but but
mostly I can the one I liked the the
most was the former Playboy Playboy
playmat mhm the disconnect between what
she was talking about and her kind of
ble glib way of of talking uh was
wonderfully tragic and train wrecky but
talking about it like she's talking
about everyday stuff exactly she's going
to order for lunch but then I noticed
that you had a kind of they said a
censored version and a not censored
version yes and I she was naming so many
names oh my gosh she was she was outing
all kinds of people so I just figured
you know this is going to be it's just
going to cause all kinds of headaches is
that anywhere it's on my subscription
channel oh okay okay okay yeah wow did
you get push back when
you're like when you're working with
like when Fight Club became a film there
must have been pushed back on some
scenes there right um there was only
push back on um
the Marlo singer's Infamous line uh when
they're in bed was that when they're in
bed yes and she said she's supposed to
say I want to have your
abortion and even Brad Pit chimed in he
said my mom's going to see this movie I
I I just I don't want that line and so
finer changed it to I haven't been
[__] like that since grade school and
at that point 20th Century Fox jumped in
and said that's worse that and finer
just put his foot down and said no
that's that's the line
oh that's
great when when you're in these writers
groups what what kind of thing are those
helpful to be working with other writers
and bouncing ideas back and
forth or is or is there
some bumping heads there too with your
freedom well the uh initially it was
wonderful because it gives you a little
party it gives you a social reward every
week for having produced work uh and so
when you're not getting you know any
kind of uh you're not selling
anything uh you just want to be heard
and also you want to check for clarity I
want to make sure that when I press the
language when I really mess with the
language it's still clear what I'm
depicting
um and so writers group are are really
good for that they're also really good
for uh cultural precedent
because nobody wants to get 100 pages
into something and then realize that
they've just written Charlotte's Web you
know somebody in the group is going to
be able to say oh I saw something like
that in a movie like this and so you
really early on you you uh you're able
to give up ideas rather than repeat
something that people already
know so it gives you a social
reinforcement for doing it it gives you
a check on your Clarity it gives you act
access to a larger cultural precedent um
gives you a certain small amount of of
useful feedback typically there's not
enough writers in Workshop who can
articulate why a thing does or does not
work so most of the time you're
listening to people say I really liked
this part I really didn't like this part
and that's completely useless you want
to know how to fix it you you want to
know what needs to be fixed and how to
fix it um but most recently our Workshop
broke up because of um political
correctness I was writing a short story
turned more or less into a
Nolla called
inclinations and it's about a
kid who wants a Corvair who wants a
Corvette so he he asks his father for a
hamster for his birthday and then he
gets his hamster and then he
uh he says the hamster got the hamster's
gone got
away but gradually he stages it so that
all these hamsters disappear and his his
parents find um a big thing of
half-filled thing of Vaseline in his
room and he's he's coaching them to
think he's putting hamsters up his butt
and they finally confront him and they
say are you putting hamsters up your
butt and he's like no and so they say we
we want to send you to this conversion
therapy and he says I'm not going I'm
not going I'm
I'm he's straight he's heterosexual he's
just a
kid but he leads him to believe that he
is homosexual through these kind of
stereotypical hamster things he's
actually putting the hamsters out the
window but he finally says okay if you
buy me a Corvette I will go to to this
uh this uh reorientation
therapy and so he thinks the whole thing
is going to be about being shown
pornographic movies and plied with
hookers and shot with steroids and he
cannot wait and at the end of all this
he gets a Corvette um so he he walks
into it it's this is whole scam on his
parents
and it's a great story it works really
well it's it that's just the tip of the
iceberg
but there are protesters outside the
Gate of
this and I used the word fat in the
story and one of my best friends in the
workshop a very bestselling writer
Chelsea she said no you can't use the
word fat
nope I said we're writers you
know I'm samex attracted why can't I use
the word f
and chelse says because we meet in my
house and you're not going to say the
word f in my
house I said you know we're cutting
ourselves off off the knee if we
cannot we start sort of dictating what
words we cannot cannot use it was so
frustrating and Chelsea said
no if you're going to bring in work with
the word f uh we're not meeting here and
I don't want to be part of Workshop
anymore and workshop more or less fell
apart that night this discussion of what
was going to be allowed and what was not
going to be allowed um and we had
depicted I me Chelsea writes about a
serial killer named Gretchen who
vivisect her her victims and they're
alive and the lungs are inflating and
deflating and the positive bowel
movements are happening in the
intestines and the whole thing is alive
and steaming while Gretchen is torturing
this man to
death and I'm
like yeah we're allowing that but we
don't allow F that's the that's the one
word on YouTube that I cannot use really
it's the one word it's funny because I
that I know of I go to my phone and I
try to put in obscene words or forbidden
words and fact the one word the phone
will take and won't autocorrect so um I
just find that so fascinating but that's
that's that was the downfall of our
workshop and I think it'll get better I
think that people are moving beyond
that I was at a Barnes & Noble in skoki
Illinois it's like the flagship Barnes &
Noble for uh the Chicago area and I
think it was for my book
rant
um
and I was telling these ryall stories
that people told me that a lot of these
stories came in on letters and there was
one guy he was a painter in Denver and
he was really proud he did really the
very best prep work he he said he he
didn't do any spray work it was all
brush work just he was you know a
fantastically good house
painter and he had had a really
checkered life he' done a lot of
intravenous drugs and he ended up uh HIV
positive and he wasn't married wasn't in
a relationship he had this little pug
dog that he just adored he loved this
little dog
and every night before he he fell asleep
he would uh jerk off in bed and he'
clean up with a water Kleenex and he'
drop it off the side of the bed and
uh every morning he'd look down and
there'd be the Pug dog shredding the
kleenex and I kind of shot myself in the
foot here because at this point he
didn't know he was HIV
positive
but he goes in for a test for new
insurance or something and they
say you've got to come in for a face to
face and that's never good so he goes in
for a face to
face and they're talking about you know
extending his life and treatments and
regiments and on and on and all he can
think of is every morning for God knows
how many years my dog has eaten those
Kleenex oh my God I gave my dog AIDS and
he's just completely freaked out it
doesn't matter whether
he's sick or he might die he is just
completely completely traumatized over
the idea that he might have killed this
thing that he loves the
most and so while the social worker is
still prattling on and on and on he
finally just he says you've got to stop
just stop I only need to know one thing
I only need to know just one thing just
stop just shut up and she
stops and you know it's clear she's got
this sort of saintly look she's given
this this talk so many
times and he goes I just need to
know could I have
given aids to my pug
dog
and he says in that moment the look on
her face just
hardens it's not a smile anymore it's
just like a muscle cramp and he says he
can actually hear her chair Creak this
wooden chair because she's so pushing
herself back trying to distance herself
in this invisible
way and the room is deadly
quiet and then Don some he he
goes oh she thinks I [__] my
dog oh my gosh he thinks I [__] my pug
dog and he goes you think I [__] my dog
oh no no no it's not like that and he
tells the story about the kleenex and
about the dog eating the kleenex and at
that point the social worker goes from
this complete disgust to this enormous
relief and she starts to laugh and she
says no there a reason it's called HIV
and not div it is human immuno
suppressive virus not dog
immuno and the two of them are so
overwhelmed with relief and joy in this
moment that his dog's not going to get
sick and she's not counseling a guy who
[__]
dogs that after that HIV is just
something they can deal with they're
both so happy and life goes on and the
guy was writing to me years and years
after the fact and he still seems to be
very well um I love that story but I
told that story at a skoki Barnes &
Noble and by the time I'd signed the
last of the people it was 130 2:00 in
the morning and the store people staff
were no longer speaking to me they were
so angry about that story and the next
day at my hotel my editor for Random
House called and just reamed me out said
how dare you tell that story that's that
was disgusting that that everyone in
Barnes & Noble is so
put off by you and so angry about that
that they are raising holy hell here at
random house um you may never tell that
story again blah blah blah and I was
really called on the carpet for it um
but I love that pug dog
story it's a you're doing the right
thing I
think for a while I was telling a story
called
guts and the very first time I sto I
told it and I almost said I stole it
because it was based on three true
stories told to me by friends over over
decades um but the first time I told it
was in the basement of a library in San
Francisco and it was a huge huge number
of people it was packed and people
fainted and there was one young young
man he must have been about 13 or 14 and
he was Asian and he was there with a
incredibly elegantly dressed Asian
woman and I I assumed that she was
probably a a grandparent who had brought
him to the event and as they came up in
the signing
line um the the kid's got his book and
I'm signing his book and at that point
the the elderly woman leans in and this
sounds terrible but with her accent she
said
uh she says she said
ah
I tell my grandson don't you never ever
stick nothing up your
penis and this poor kid is just dying
he's just wilting like oh [__] grandma
grandma grandma and you you can tell
that she drove him there and that she is
going to be sharing that story with him
for the rest of his life oh it was such
a wonderful heartbreaking moment uh the
look in that poor kid's face but uh yeah
that was a moment but out of that same
event a woman came up and she'd come A
huge distance I believe it was from
crous Bay
Oregon and she told a story about how
when she was in second grade she'd been
uh she'd been a brownie and brownies are
a precursor to uh Girl
Scouts
and you get a little brown hat and you
have to earn merit
badges and each week you meet at a
different Brownie's house and she was
not a a popular kid she she had very few
friends in second
grade but once she got a stomach ache
and her mother kept her out of school
and at the time this would have been in
the 60s they had a a a heating pad with
this vibrating function and so she had
to sleep on her stomach with the heating
pad on her stomach and somehow during
the night the heating pad slid down
between her legs this gentle warm
vibrating thing and she said she woke up
with the most fantastic incredible
feeling just glorious like nothing she
had ever
experienced and so the next time it was
her turn to host the brownies she said
brownies you got to come to my house you
all got to try this heating pad this
heating pad thing I invented it's
amazing and so all the brownies rode
this heating pad and they all had these
fantastic fantastic
experiences and uh and she said after
that every Brownie meeting was at my
house every girl in the second grade
wanted to play at my house and it was
like sex in the city for seven-year-old
girls and we all got along and for that
one bright shining moment I was the most
popular kid in my
class until the one day my mom came home
from work early and she caught us with
the heating
pad and she very politely asked all the
brownies to
leave and when they were all
gone she grabbed the cord and she yanked
it out of the
wall
and went at me just beat me with that
cord my mom just beat me and beat me
with that heating pad cord that
electrical cord and she just beat me and
beat me and beat me and the whole time
she was beating me she was saying you
[__] you dirty dirty [__] you dirty
dirty [__] what kind of a [__] [__]
am I
raising and the woman who's telling me
the
story is not telling it in a tragic
way she's telling it in a kind of way
that something is something has shifted
and it's because I've read that gut
story in which in the first person I'm
talking about a character who who puts a
carrot up his butt and another character
who puts a a length of wax down his
penis and another character who's
disemboweled by a swimming pool filter
but since I read it in the first person
I'm more or less embodying all of these
acts um and she says this woman with a
heating pad she says if you can tell
those stories about you know jerking off
in a swimming
pool if you can tell those stories and
make people laugh at them about what you
did then I can tell my heating pad story
and I can make that story a story that
people laugh at
and that
ultimately she said you know I have not
had an orgasm since the second grade but
maybe someday I'll be able to have an
orgasm and beyond that maybe someday I
can go back to my mother and I can say
do you remember that heating pad we had
and I can complete this enormous
incomplete with my
mom and so that's another big aspect of
why I write what I write
because our entire lives can be about
this enormous effort to look good and to
always look
good and to never sort of show any kind
of
belly but if we recognize that that
gives us a freedom to to really show
belly when we want to and to kind of be
of service to people and to be able to
kind of throw away the really kind of
small things that we find ourselves on
occasion you know I find myself getting
smaller and smaller and
smaller as I get smarter and it really
takes a kind of sort of self self-
ulating story to kind of blow me back
out so that I'm really in the world
again um and so it's about reading a
story in which I kind of throw away all
human dignity
um and in turn I'm given something
greater than this small sort of looking
good thing that I was up to that moment
um and also you do that service for your
for your readership or for your audience
because you give them the same freedom
to kind of step out of looking good for
a moment uh and throw throw everything
away that's great what what are you
proudest of in your
life H what am I proudest stuff in my
life
um my
marriage yeah I can't believe 30 years
yeah it's uh 30 years 30 years uh 10
years married but 20 years together
before that and it's been a a
strange uh 30 years because I when we
were first together I uh I wasn't really
a writer so we both had to kind of you
know experience this this
strange seismic
shift how has your life changed since
you
became a well-known
writer
um as opposed to being an employee at
Freight ler
yeah the biggest way my life has changed
is that the weather is so much nicer now
because when I work at Freightliner I
could only go out outside During certain
moments of certain days and if it was
always if it was raining during that
time it was raining and now I can go
outside anytime the sun shines so now my
perception of the weather is that the
weather is infinitely better than it
used to be because it used to be that I
got what I got there were only so many
hours that I could go out and be in the
world and now I can be in the world
anytime I want so I get to choose when I
enjoy the weather and the weather seems
that much
nicer what are you working on now ah
what am I working
on I working on a science fiction novel
that
is really strange because I loved
science fiction as a kid and I really
want to take a shot at it in completely
Reinventing it in an oddball way and I
have been uh commissioned by the steppen
Wolf Theater Company of Chicago to write
a play um I've always wanted to write a
play because uh a play seems like the
ultimate form of minimalism every aspect
every element in a play the characters
the settings the time everything is so
limited and you have to do so much with
such limited stuff that I I a play has
always been my dream and so um I'm
already writing the play we haven't even
started meetings but steepen
wolf and Chuck what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
H uh most important
lesson to take responsibility for my own
uh
experience uh that this sounds really
abstract but
um I'm never going to work a job I
hate uh without finding a way to to like
it even when I was on the assembly line
at Freightliner there were all these
fantastic jokes that that I would play
and that I would sort of prompt other
people to play um the uh the vendor reps
who came by with like new way axles and
uh different you know cummin engines
these vendor reps would always bring
these huge cardboard boxes full of
donuts the most elaborate filled Donuts
you could imagine just every kind of
crawler everything Bavarian cream
everything jelly just huge like 40
pounds of gorgeous
doughnuts and they would put them open
on somebody's workbench in in the in the
factory and it was always a blast to
take the the the grease gun and to put
the grease gun in where the Bavarian
cream was injected and to shoot the
doughnut full of axle grease and then to
put some powder sugar over that spot to
hide it and put it back in the box and
then for everybody to hide behind the
parts racks and wait for somebody to
take just that doughnut and to bite into
it and get a big mouthful of axle grease
because you can't spit out axle grease
it sticks to everything and so the
person would bite down get this moment
of horror this gagging vomiting look and
then instantly look around because they
knew they were being watched
and then the Fantastic rage this person
with a a mouthful of axle grease that
they couldn't spit out would then be
looking for tools to beat someone with
and everyone would be laughing and
running um that was fun the other thing
I love to do was uh buy these little uh
really adorable stuffed
animals because so often when you're uh
running uh wiring harnesses or other
things that you have to run through the
the frame rails of a truck you you can't
really see where you're reaching you
just have to reach sort of shoulder deep
to to try to find the component or find
the loose thing whatever you're working
on so you're reaching blindly into these
these deep dark
spaces and the uh the the truck building
plant also had a rat problem so there
was always this uh Terror that you going
to reach into these places and there
would be a rat and so taking a small
stuffed animal and putting it at this
inaccessible place so someone would re
reaching in to to work in Airline or
something they would grab this fuzzy
thing and instantly in Terror think it
was a rat but then ultimately Discover
it was this adorable stuffed
animal and everybody who worked at the
plant they either had small kids at home
who would love that animal or they had a
girlfriend who would love that animal so
it would be something that would morph
from a moment of complete Terror to a
moment of complete joy as they realized
that they could gift this to someone who
would really love it um so it was those
kind of jokes that uh that made working
at the plant a lot of fun and no matter
what job I've had it's always been
about my first priority is how do I make
this fun how do I take responsibility
for my
experience um and and make this task
something that I will
enjoy as Dudley Moore said in the movie
Arthur fun is the best thing to have
fun yes or money
yeah all right Chuck P thank you so much
dear God how long did we go an hour and
40 minutes
jeez you did
great